Bonjour! Le mois dernier j'ai commencé
à vous parler de Game of Thrones parce que
c'était de saison, et ce mois ci on va reparler
de Game of Thrones parce que c'est toujours
de saison.
-Mortelle, comme intro. Eh mais on est invitées,
cette fois?
-Ouais, Arya m'a envoyé un corbeau «Je
suis personne, laisse-moi tranquille.»
C'est une phase, je pense...
Bref, c'est bien joli de parler de bâtiments
mais Game of Thrones est tout de même réputé
pour une chose: la mort.
-Valar Morghulis.
-Eh...
-C'est juste une réutilisation de rushs.
Loin de moi l'idée de vous faire une liste
exhaustive de toutes les morts de Game of
Thrones pour vous dire «eh, eh, vous voyez,
ben Plouclord de Pétaouchnoc en 1237 il est
mort EXACTEMENT comme ça, tout pareil».
Ça serait long et pas hyper constructif.
Du coup j'ai juste repris quelques passages
particulièrement marquants de la série et
on va surtout s'attarder sur des assassinats,
des procès mortels, des morts en temps de
guerre et des morts con.
Comme la dernière fois je risque de spoiler
comme une prêtresse de Rh'llor lisant dans
les flammes donc vous êtes prévenus, et
c'est parti.
Deux assassinats dans Game of Thrones ont
particulièrement marqué les esprits, parce
qu'ils provoquaient des retournements de situation
foufous dans la série, mais ils évoquent
aussi des événements historiques bien de
chez nous.
Le premier, c'est l'assassinat de Jon Snow.
Pour la faire courte Jon est nommé Lord Commandant
de la Garde de Nuit grâce à la manière
dont il a défendu le Mur contre l'attaque
de sauvageons menée par Mance Raider. Et
aussi grâce à ses copains qui font bien
campagne pour lui.
-Avez-vous entendu parler de Jon Snow? Malgré
le silence des corbeaux?
-Bref, pif pouf le voilà commandant sauf
que ça ne plaît pas à Allister Thorne,
déjà, qui n'a de toute façon jamais pu
le blairer.
Sa décision peu après son élection de faire
franchir le mur aux sauvageons restants, pour
s'allier à eux et protéger plus efficacement
les Sept Couronnes contre les marcheurs blancs,
choque pas mal de monde et le rend impopulaire
auprès d'une partie de la Garde.
En plus il promet de leur refiler des terres
dans la région du Don, qu'ils ne se privaient
pas de piller depuis des millénaires avant
ça. Samwell Tarly est en route vers Villevieille,
mestre Aemon est mort – slash – parti
aussi selon si vous préférez le livre ou
la série, et ça laisse la voix libre à
ses détracteurs pour un bon petit assassinat.
Dans la série, cet assassinat est particulièrement
mis en scène: Olly, le protégé de Jon
puisqu'il l'avait nommé son intendant personnel,
l'attire dehors jusqu'à un poteau affichant
«traître». Il reçoit ensuite un coup
de couteau d'Allister Thorne, puis des conjurés
chacun leur tour, avant de finir par Olly,
chacun déclarant «pour la Garde» en
faisant leur affaire. Des gars plutôt rancuniers.
Dans cette mise en scène on retrouve très
clairement une référence à l'assassinat
de Jules César.
Je vais pas m'attarder sur la comparaison
parce que Nota Bene en parle déjà dans l'une
de ses vidéos, dont je placerai le lien dans
la description mais pour la faire courte César
est assassiné en 44 avant J.C. notamment
parce que bon nombre de ses ennemis craignaient
qu'il ne cherche à rétablir la monarchie
à Rome.
-Je peux? La monarchie était abolie à
Rome depuis des siècles et nous en gardions
un très mauvais souvenir, hors de question
de revivre ça. Alors quand Jules César s'est
nommé dictateur perpétuel... Certains ont
vu rouge.
-Il est aussi plutôt proche du groupe des
populares, les gens qui sont plutôt pour
la solidarité, en opposition aux optimates
qui sont attachés à leurs privilèges et
recherchent le maintien d'une vraie oligarchie
de droit divin... avec un S?
Bref brouf tout ça fait qu'il a pas mal d'ennemis
à Rome, et ces ennemis ourdissent un complot
de 60 à 80 conjurés dirigés par Caïus
Cassius Longinus, et parmi lesquels on compte
aussi le fils adoptif de César, Brutus.
-Le 15 mars 44 avant J.C., ils sont une trentaine
à attendre César au Sénat, où le port
des armes est interdit. Ils s'assemblent autour
de lui, l'immobilisent et l'assassinent de
23 coups de poignard avant de se disperser.
-Il s'agit d'un assassinat pas super préparé,
pour la République qui ne fait de toute manière
pas de vieux os après ça et pour leurs intérêts
personnels aussi. Les conjurés meurent tous
dans les trois années qui suivent et pas
de leur belle mort.
Bon, Jon Snow s'est fait assassiner, Jules
César s'est fait assassiner, plein d'autres
gens aussi, où est la référence?
-Mais j'en sais rien moi! Demande à ceux
qui font les fouilles!
-La mise en scène. Dans les deux cas on a
une mise à mort par un groupe de conjurés,
qui prennent leur ennemi par surprise et lui
plantent chacun leur tour un coup de poignard
dans le ventre. La référence est particulièrement
marquante via le personnage de Olly, que Jon
avait pris sous son aile pour en faire potentiellement
son successeur, et qui rappelle donc Brutus.
-Valar Morghulis.
L'autre trahison plutôt marquante concerne
Robb Stark, lors des Noces Pourpres ou «Red
Wedding». Je passe un peu plus vite sur
les événements cette fois parce que contrairement
à ma vidéo sur les monuments dans Game of
Thrones, qui ont tout un background très
peu développé dans la série et disséminé
dans les livres, il y a de fortes chances
pour que vous vous soyez pris les Noces Pourpres
en pleine face.
Et de même pour les autres événements que
j'aborderai ici et qui sont déjà assez clairs
rien qu'en regardant la série. Pas comme
l'histoire de la construction du phare de
Villevieille.
Du coup, Robb avait scellé une alliance avec
les Frey pour traverser leur pont avec son
armée, mais en échange il devait épouser
une des filles ou petites-filles Frey. Pas
de bol pour le vieux Walder, il tombe amoureux,
de Talysa Maegyr dans la série et de Jeyne
Ouestrelin dans les livres. A partir de là
il est bien obligé de frayer à nouveau avec
les Frey parce qu'il a toujours besoin de
leurs troupes et de leur pont, alors à la
place il est décidé que son oncle Edmure,
héritier des Tully, épousera une fille Frey.
-On dit pas fraîche?
-Pour comprendre à quel point Walder Frey
ne gagne pas au change, en mariant sa fille
à Robb Stark il aurait eu une reine, pas
de tout Westeros certes quoi qu'il pouvait
toujours imaginer ce qu'il voulait. Il aurait
pu en profiter pour pas mal s'impliquer dans
toute la politique du Nord et de Navarre,
alors qu'au lieu de ça on lui propose juste
une lady Tully, la grande famille noble du
coin, youpi.
Walder fait donc une petite alliance avec
les Lannister en secret, reçoit les Stark
dans leur château où tout le monde festoie
gaiement jusqu'à ce que la chanson des Lannister,
Les Pluies de Castamere, soit jouée pour
annoncer le début du massacre. On peut penser
que Robb Stark était naïf de se croire pardonné
aussi vite, mais les lois de l'hospitalité
à Westeros font que si on partage le pain
et le sel sous le même toit on est censé
ressortir de ce toit en toute amitié, d'où
l'importance de cette scène où Edmure essaie
discrètement de cache qu'il s'est foutu des
miettes partout.
A travers l'Histoire, les assassinats en plein
repas sont plutôt courants.
-Si c'est avant le dessert, c'est vraiment
dégueulasse.
-En 276, par exemple, l'empereur Probus aurait
invité les généraux responsables de la
mort de son prédécesseur à un grand banquet
avant de se retirer dans une autre pièce
et de les laisser se faire massacrer.
-On retrouve plus de ressemblances avec les
noces pourpres dans l'assassinat suivant:
en 749, Abou al-Abbas rêve de devenir calife
à la place du calife. A cette époque c'est
la dynastie omeyyade qui règne sur l'empire
d'Islam, mais qu'à cela ne tienne: il se
fait proclamer et force le calife omeyyade
à fuir en Egypte.
Dans une offre de réconciliation, en 750,
il invite toute la famille omeyyade à un
grand banquet à Damas. Au cours de ce repas
un poète, Sodaïf, est invité
et déclame:
Et là, c'est le massacre. Ce procédé nous
rappelle pas mal les Pluies de Castamere jouées
pour annoncer le début du massacre des Stark.
Chez les omeyyades, un seul parvient à s'enfuir
en Espagne et à fonder l'émirat omeyyade
de Cordoue, mais le pouvoir à Damas reste
aux mains des abbassides, puis d'autres familles...
Mais plus jamais des Omeyyades.
Le dernier assassinat dont je vais parler
utilise aussi le procédé de «t'entends
cette musique qui t'annonce que tu vas prendre
cher?»
Aliénor mange un truc et prend un air effrayé
alors que Bella de Maître Gims commence
Nous sommes en 1440, En Ecosse. Le jeune roi
James II est monté sur le trône depuis peu
et n'a que neuf ans. Il est sous la régence
de Sir Douglas, mais ce dernier meurt de la
peste. Deux autres personnages, Sir Chrichton
et Sir Livingston, qui n'est pas un goéland,
se partagent alors la régence mais craignent
encore que le fils de Douglas, William, ne
nuise à leurs projets: William a quinze
ans, il a 5000 hommes à ses ordres et le
roi James II l'adore.
Chrichton et Livingston invitent donc William
Douglas et son petit frère à un banquet,
on commence à connaître la musique, où
ils sont très bien accueillis, honorés,
même le jeune roi est présent... Jusqu'à
ce que le son des cornemuses retentisse et
à l'époque ça ne signifiait pas qu'on allait
pouvoir danser la bourrée mais plutôt:
la guerre. D'après certains récits des servants
auraient aussi apporté une tête de taureau
noir aux deux garçons, un symbole de mort.
Une mise en scène plutôt explicite quoi,
au cas où ils n'auraient pas compris.
-Le Sinistros!
-Alors que le roi James II est pas trop d'accord
avec ce qui se passe mais, pour rappel, il
n'a que neuf ans, les deux Douglas sont saisis
par des soldats et conduits à l'extérieur
pou y être exécutés. Ce dîner reste connu
comme le Black Dinner ou Black Douglas.
-A ne pas confondre avec le black pudding.
Qui est du boudin.
-Des tas d'autres assassinats d'hôtes ont
pu inspirer Georges Martin: la tentative
de massacre pendant un mariage à Heworth
Moor, le massacre de Glen Coe, le massacre
de Stockholm... Bref, protégez-vous: mangez
seul.
-Valar Morghulis.
Tyrion Lannister a ce manque de bol de subir
deux procès au cours de la série, tout en
étant innocent à chaque fois. Son manque
flagrant de karma nous permet d'aborder la
manière dont sont menés les procès dans
l'univers de Game of Thrones, et surtout comment
ils se règlent assez souvent.
Le premier procès de Tyrion a lieu dans la
saison 1 lorsqu'il est accusé de la tentative
de meurtre contre Bran Stark. Il est alors
capturé par Catelyn Stark et conduit en prison
sans passer par la case départ, aux Eyriés,
pour être jugé par Lysa Arryn. Le procès
n'est pas super équitable: Tyrion n'a que
sa parole pour le défendre et sent qu'il
risque de finir au fond du trou. Et au fond
de ce trou là, y'a pas vraiment de fond.
Du coup il invoque le pif-pouf c'est pas moi
des procès médiévaux: l'ordalie, ici
un duel judiciaire qui permettra aux dieux
de décider qui est le coupable.
-Et effectivement, coup de bol, c'était pas
lui.
-La deuxième fois, il est jugé dans le cadre
de l'assassinat de Jeoffrey Baratheon-Lannister-ça
dépend. Encore un assasinat pendant un mariage,
bravo les valeurs.
Joffrey était un petit con
Même pas un vrai Baratheon
Il aimait les prostituées
Simplement pour les zigouiller
Olenna Tyrell préférait un gendre plus tendre
Aussi lui offrit un peu de vin pour le détendre.
-Valar Morghulis.
Mais puisque Tyrion était de notoriété
publique en froid avec son neveu, comme Cersei
le déteste et parce que c'est un prétexte
parfait pour se débarrasser de ce Lannister
trop gênant, on décide que ce sera lui le
coupable.
Sentant qu'il risque d'être condamné et
provoqué par le témoignage de Shae à son
encontre, il demande à nouveau un duel judiciaire
en espérant que ce qui a déjà marché une
fois marchera une deuxième fois. Pas de chance
cette fois, son champion, Oberyn, est tout
aussi préoccupé par sa vengeance personnelle
et termine en pastèque.
Si on s'était trouvé dans notre monde, de
toute façon, ce duel n'aurait probablement
pas pu avoir lieu de cette manière: le
déséquilibre entre l'armure de la Montagne
et celle d'Oberyn, et le recours au poison
par ce dernier auraient été interdits. Les
armes, armures et même l'aiguisage de la
lame étaient souvent contrôlés et devaient
être le plus identiques possibles. Et pas
le droit de faire pouce.
Dans Game of Thrones les duels judiciaires
sont une alternative à une forme de jugement
plus traditionnelle, faisant intervenir un
juge et des témoins. L'accusé peut demander
à être jugé plutôt par un duel, et on
voit que ça se produit généralement quand
il sent que le procès ne tourne pas en sa
faveur. Il y a quand même quelques restrictions:
l'accusé doit appartenir à la noblesse.
Accusé et accusateur peuvent se battre eux-même,
ou désigner un champion à leur place qui
doit être volontaire.
-Le combat peut exceptionnellement prendre
la forme d'une grosse baston à sept contre
sept, qu'on appelle judicieusement le Jugement
des Sept, rapport à la religion locale.
-Durant le haut MA, il existait plusieurs
moyens de rendre la justice. Celle-ci se basait
sur le serment et les ordalies, des épreuves
qui pouvaient consister en se tenir debout
sur une croix le plus longtemps possible,
tenir des charbons ardents... Plein de joyeusetés
qui visaient à prouver l'innocence de l'accusé,
puisqu'il était coupable jusqu'à preuve
du contraire. Logique.
Les duels judiciaires correspondent aux ordalies
bilatérales, on les appelle aussi duellum
bellum. L'accusé et l'accusateur doivent
alors s'affronter devant les autorités laïques
et que le plus innocent gagne. Cette pratique
est pourtant de plus en plus critiquée par
l’Église qui y voit une instrumentalisation
de la justice divine: les ordalies sont
interdites en 855 par le concile de Vienne,
même si elles restent en vigueur jusqu'au
XIIIe siècle. Elles sont ensuite interdites
par Louis IX en 1258, et le droit romain réapparaît
peu à peu.
-Merci de reconnaître notre supériorité.
-Dans la série on retrouve le même schéma
puisque Tommen interdit le duel judiciaire,
juste avant le procès de sa mère, très
influencé par le Grand Moineau qui cherche
à rétablir la vraie justice divine. Et ça
pourrit les plans de Cercei.
Si vous aimez les ordalies, Angle Droit avait
fait une chouette vidéo sur le sujet que
je partagerai aussi en description, parce
que le partage, c'est beau.
On en arrive donc aux morts cons, et pour
ça je ne vais pas m'attarder sur certains
personnages décédant sur leurs toilettes
mais plutôt vous parler de cochons et autres
porcidés.
Robert Baratheon adore chasser. Il adore aussi
l'alcool, ce qui arrange bien Cercei: en
passant par l'écuyer du roi, Lancel Lannister,
elle fait empoisonner son vin pour faire passer
sa mort pour un accident de chasse. Seulement,
dans l'histoire, Cercei et Lancel ne sont
pas les seuls responsables de sa mort: accordons
la place qui lui est due au sanglier.
Sous l'emprise de son vin empoisonné, Robert
Baratheon voit ses talents de chasseur bien
diminués mais s'éloigne tout de même de
sa troupe pour tenter de mettre à mort la
bête. Pas de bol, le sanglier ne se laisse
pas avoir si facilement et embroche Robert
avant de mourir.
-Baratheon à la broche.
-Le sanglier n'est donc pas le seul responsable,
mais même si des doutes sur la mort du roi
apparaissent très tôt, la version officielle
est bien l'accident de chasse.
Ces récits de rois tués par des cochons
sont assez courantes au cours de l'Histoire,
les nobles pratiquant la chasse depuis bien
longtemps en tant que loisir de riche et symbole
de leur puissance.
C'est le cas de Louis V, qui meurt en 987
écrasé par son propre cheval après que
le sanglier qu'il essayait de chasser ne lui
fonce dessus. Sa mort met fin à la dynastie
des carolingiens, son successeur est donc
Hugues Capet.
Le destin porcin s'acharne ensuite sur les
Philippe: Philippe de France, le fils de
Louis VI le gros, était destiné à devenir
roi à la mort de son père et déjà associé
au pouvoir dès l'âge de treize ans. Cette
préparation à l'accession au trône ne dure
malheureusement pas longtemps: le 13 octobre
1131, alors qu'il se déplace à cheval dans
Paris, son cheval croise le chemin d'un porc
plutôt nerveux, se cabre, fait tomber le
prince et l'écrase sous son poids. Philippe
meurt peu après, et le trône revient par
la suite à son petit frère. Selon certains
historiens et notamment Michel Pastoureau,
qui a écrit un livre sur le sujet, la mort
de Philippe de France a des conséquences
importantes pour le royaume: elle place
sur le trône le jeune Louis VII, qui était
destiné à devenir ecclésiastique comme
c'était souvent le cas des seconds nés.
Il connaît donc mal l'exercice du pouvoir
et ça se ressent durant son règne, mais
ce serait une histoire bien trop longue à
raconter. En plus y'a déjà un Confessions
d'Histoire sur le sujet. Décidément c'est
l'épisode des partages.
Michel Pastoureau émet aussi la thèse, qui
paraît vraisemblable pour plusieurs historiens,
que la mort de Philippe de France à cause
d'un cochon, animal considéré comme sale
et impur, soit la raison pour laquelle son
père choisit par la suite comme emblème
royal la fleur de lys et le bleu, les symboles
de la Vierge, pour faire oublier ce passage
un peu honteux.
-Quel martyr quand personne peut plus vous
sentir.
-Disgrâce infâme.
-Enfin, quelques générations plus tard,
Philippe le Bel se trouve lui aussi en pleine
partie de chasse en 1314 lorsque, encore une
fois, le sanglier choisit de charger le cheval,
et paf le roi. Il est blessé mais surtout
se retrouve soudain incapable de parler, en
proie à des maux d'estomac, les médecins
n'y comprennent rien... Il meurt quelques
semaines plus tard, et les chroniqueurs sont
partagés sur la responsabilité de cette
maladie inconnue ou du sanglier.
-Tu m'étonnes qu'avec tout ça le sanglier
soit associé au diable.
-Avec nos connaissances actuelles, il est
possible que Philippe le Bel soit en fait
mort d'un AVC.
-Valar Morghulis.
Game of Thrones, c'est aussi de la bagarre,
et l'une des plus marquantes est la bataille
de la Néra qui oppose l'armée de Stannis
aux soldats de Port-Réal. Stannis vient de
tuer son frère Renly et de récupérer tous
ses bannerets au passage et attaque Port-Réal
par le fleuve.
De son côté, Tyrion, nommé main du roi,
prépare très minutieusement la défense
de la cité: il renforce les murailles,
y place tous les manteaux d'or accompagnés
de quelques trébuchets et catapultes, et
envoie les tribus des collines dans le Bois-du-Roi,
au sud de la ville, pour empêcher les éclaireurs
de Stannis de passer. Surtout, il a un plan:
ayant appris que Cercei faisait refaire le
stock de feu grégeois de la ville il réquisitionne
le tout et en charge 13 000 pots dans des
navires. Une chaîne bloque l'entrée du fleuve
pour la flotte de Stannis, et celle-ci n'a
pas le temps de réagir lorsqu'elle constate
que les navires de la capitale répandent
un drôle de liquide vert sur leur passage:
BOUM.
La majorité de la flotte est détruite, et
le reste débarque à la porte de la Gadoue
mais est finalement repoussé.
Cette bataille et surtout l'intervention du
feu grégeois nous ramènent chez les omeyyades
dont on avait vu la fin un peu plus tôt,
et plus précisément au conflit qui oppose
le calife Suleyman et l'empereur byzantin
Anastase II.
Au début du VIIIe siècle, le conflit entre
les deux empires est ouvert depuis un moment
et le calife Suleyman prépare un nouveau
siège de Constantinople, LA ville à prendre.
-Ça va, c'est pas Byzance non plus.
-Ben, si. Faut te mettre à jour un peu. Pas
de bol pour le calife, Anastase est au courant.
Tel un Tyrion des temps pas si modernes, il
fait rehausser les murailles de la ville,
prévoit des stocks de nourriture et chasse
une partie de la population, ce qui est moins
sympa quand on sait que pendant ce temps les
troupes de Suleyman avancent en pillant tout
sur leur passage. Au printemps 716, le siège
commence, et les troupes du calife sont beaucoup
plus nombreuses que celle de Constantinople.
La ville n'a plus aucun moyen de ravitaillement
et semble perdue, mais quelle est cette lueur
à l'horizon?
-Gandalf?
-Le feu grégeois. Les byzantins mettent le
feu aux navires du calife, et c'est le chaos.
Cette victoire permet aux byzantins de gagner
du temps, de s'allier avec les bulgares pendant
l'hiver 717 et de dégager définitivement
les troupes du calife de la région. Pour
l'empereur Anastase, par contre, le destin
est moins sympa: une révolte de l'armée
le contraint à se retirer du pouvoir avant
d'être décapité en 719. En même temps
si on suit le lien avec Tyrion, on ne peut
pas dire que Port-Réal lui soit très reconnaissante
non plus d'avoir défendu la ville.
Le feu grégeois est donc une arme connue
de l'Antiquité et du MA. On le retrouve dès
le IXe siècle avant JC chez les Assyriens,
il est aussi mentionné durant la guerre du
Péloponnèse qui oppose en gros les athéniens
et les spartates, puis chez les byzantins
à partir du VIe siècle. On le retrouve ensuite
en Occident, aux XIe et XIIe siècle: il
était probablement composé de naphte, de
résine de pin, de chaux vive, de soufre ou
de salpêtre, ou peut-être d'oxyde de calcium,
ou encore de pétrole, mais sa composition
exacte reste inconnue ce qui explique sa progressive
disparition. Les armées arabes et bulgares
qui s'emparent du feu grégeois ne parviennent
pas à le copier malgré de nombreuses tentatives,
et l'usage de plus en plus répandu de la
poudre à canon à partir du XIVe siècle
rend le secret de la recette du feu grégeois
moins important de toute manière. Il n'est
plus mentionné après la prise de Constantinople
de 1453.
-Valar Morghulis! Ça veut dire quoi en
fait...
-Memento Mori.
Si on résume notre propos très simplement
jusqu'ici: les gens meurent. Et ce fait
connu de tous est résumé dans l'univers
de Game of Thrones par cette phrase célèbre:
valar morghulis. Cette expression en haut
valyrien se traduit par «tout homme doit
mourir» et semble être une devise courante
sur tout le continent d'Essos: on la retrouve
aussi bien à Braavos, où la réponse courante
est «valar dohaerys».
-Tout homme doit servir.
-Que dans l'est du continent puisque Missandei
et Daenerys semblent très bien la connaître.
-Pour l'anecdote cette phrase peut aussi se
traduire par «Les puissances de la sorcellerie»:
dans l'oeuvre de Tolkien, «valar» signifie
«puissance» en quenya et «morghul»
signifie socellerie en sindarin, deux des
langues elfiques de la terre du Milieu.
-Frodon?!
-Si on revient au sens premier de cette phrase,
elle peut être perçue comme une incitation
à prendre conscience qu'on va tous mourir
un jour.
Au MA, on retrouve la même idée avec la
formule du memento mori, qu'on traduit couramment
en «souviens-toi que tu vas mourir»
même si elle signifie plutôt «prépare-toi
à mourir».
-Oui, mori est au présent, merci bien.
-Cette formule devient très populaire à
la fin du MA. On la retrouve à travers les
représentations de danses macabres, puis
de natures mortes. De manière générale,
si on trouve un crâne dans une œuvre quelconque
de l'époque, le sens n'est pas compliqué
à trouver.
Tu vas mourir. Eh, t'as pensé à la mort?
Tu vas mourir. T'es prêt à mourir? Ne
pêche pas trop, tu vas mourir. Retrouvez
toutes nos offres de pompes funèbres dans
notre catalogue ou par téléphone au 06 06
06 06 06.
A partir du XVIe s'ajoute à cette formule
le célèbre «carpe diem» qui incite
à profiter de la vie, puisque, comme chacun
sait,
Tu vas mourir
-Valar Morghulis.
Voilà j'espère que ces deux épisodes dérivés
de Game of Thrones vous ont plu. J'aurais
pu aborder beaucoup d'autres points mais la
vie est courte et les sujets historiques nombreux
donc la prochaine fois on reviendra sur de
l'Histoire, tout simplement. Comme je le rappelle
quand je pense à l'écrire dans mon script,
vous pouvez toujours vous abonner, partager,
commenter, voire même faire un tour sur Tipeee
ou Utip pour fournir quelques piécettes
au travail que je fais sur cette chaîne.
A bientôt, valar morghulis.